vacciner plus impossible pour ce centre
de vaccination à sarcelles qui déplore
un approvisionnement en vaccins au
compte gouttes
or les tributaires des dotations qui
nous sont affectés par la grèce donc ça
se fait à peu à flux tendu très
honnêtement
donc on peut savoir quelques jours avant
si on a une dotation supplémentaire
donc on arrive en fonction des ses
dotations à calais le nombre de rendez
vous difficile donc de répondre à la
demande croissante de vaccination dont
les départements du val d'oise qui
enregistre le taux d'infection le plus
élevé de l'hexagone une problématique
qui s'étend à tout le territoire
depuis le lancement de la vaccination en
france le 27 décembre dernier
le pays aurait reçu près de 16 millions
de doses
de quoi vacciner 8 millions de personnes
loin de la quantité nécessaire pour
atteindre l'immunité collective dans un
pays qui compte 67 millions d'habitants
pour y parvenir des vaccins vont être
produits sur le territoire national
annonce ce dimanche de thierry breton
le commissaire européen en charge de la
taxe force vaccin trois sites fabriquons
les vaccins en france dès ce mercredi le
laboratoire delpharm à saint rémy sur
avre dans l'eure et loir commencera le
flaconnage du sérum de pfizer ventech à
la fin du mois ce sera au tour de recife
armes pour modern art hamon en indre et
loire
enfin le laboratoire sanofi à marcy
l'étoile près de lyon produira à partir
de septembre
le vaccin de johnson and johnson
produire localement une stratégie
européenne en tout 53 site devrait
produire des vaccins dans l'union
européenne
objectif assurer la protection de ses
450 millions d'habitants face au court
aux navires us d'ici à la mi juillet
malgré les difficultés
d'approvisionnement bruxelles entend
poursuivre sa politique d'ouverture
selon tirer breton 60% des doses seront
à destination des états membres 40% pour
l'exporter